crusading was one of medieval europe's
favorite pastimes
it wouldn't take much for a pope to
issue a call to crusade and soon kings
princes and lords would be marching an
army to either retake the holy land or
generally just make life difficult for
the islamic powers on the other side of
the mediterranean
yet as you'll know one day the crusade
stopped but why
why did the era of crusading come to an
end now when most people discuss
crusading it's often in reference to
those in the middle east
but it's important to remember that
there were several against pagans in
northern and eastern europe
furthermore there were those in the
iberian peninsula and also ones which
were directed against the heretical
movements throughout europe in the 13th
14th and 15th centuries
those in the iberian peninsula stopped
because simply the christians won and
all of the muslim states there were
extinguished by
for the crusades in the middle east
those came to an end in the late 13th
century for several more complicated
reasons
the first was that the crusaders kept
losing and you can only keep trying the
same thing so many times before it just
seemed silly
another reason was that the primary
region of the crusades had now moved to
north africa and much of their focus was
on trade and piracy
they were now much smaller in scale and
were primarily done in a kingdom's
interest not for religious seal
furthermore many were now undertaken
without the consent of the pope which
leads into one of the main reasons that
these former crusades came to an end
the papacy's power began to decline and
everyone started to ignore them
this was due to several factors first
there were numerous schisms and are such
numerous popes who had different rulers
acknowledged them this meant the
crusading became much more risky since
previously going on a crusade meant that
the pope would excommunicate anyone who
invaded you during that time
and if you rejected the pope who
sanctioned the crusade you could just
wait until your rival's army left for
the holy land and in you end
the second reason for the papacy's
decline was the protestant reformation
which meant that many places were now
permanently out of the pope's sphere of
influence
and many of those who remained were now
dealing with internal religious conflict
so did this mean the end of formal
crusading well kind of but also
no there were still large wars involving
numerous christian states which occurred
under the direction of the pope
although not via papal bulls most of
those issued around this time were
ignored
the most notable of these religious wars
were those of the holy league against
the ottoman empire these weren't to
restore the holy land or reconquer
constantinople but to slow and
ultimately halt the ottoman expansion in
the mediterranean and europe
this didn't work immediately but it
wasn't long until the ottoman empire
began its long terminal decline
and european nations soon operated in
terms of independent national foreign
policy
and not with any sense of the united
christian world trying to reclaim
important religious cities
it was national self-interest which
would direct foreign wars after this
and that continued all the way to the
capture of jerusalem by the british in
world war one
who were very quick to dismiss any
religious undertones to the conquest
because by then the idea of a christian
religious war was
completely bizarre i hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with a special thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly money maker rob
waterhouse moe
marvin cassell aaron the white jordan
longley james castaneda gustav swan
jerry landon
maggie patzkowski copper tone rasheed
ali winston k
wood misses it spinning three plates
lexi schwinn matthew shipley anthony
beckett robert wetzel
marcus no corso wolf spencer lightfoot
and charles the first